histoire qui a énormément fait réagir
sur les réseaux sociaux des militants
écologistes ont bloqué une autoroute au
sud de Paris en s'allongeant au sol une
action du groupe qui souhaitait dénoncer
le recours aux énergies fossiles mais
qui a surtout créé d'énormes
embouteillages des embouteillages qu'on
suscité de très grosses tensions entre
les manifestants et les automobilistes
bloqués sur la 6 et quand il y a des
embouteillages forcément il y a de la
pollution mais ça ils l'ont oublié
c'était en plus la route de l'aéroport
donc certains ont eu peur de rater leur
avion et ont donc tenté de repousser des
manifestants sur le bord de la route
alors soutenez-vous le mouvement on en
parle dans un instant avec Rachel
militante qui a participé à l'action et
vendredi et Loïc porte-parole de
dernière rénovation Loïc qui sera là
dites la vérité il y en a qui les
soutiennent et c'est bien voilà ce qui
les soutiennent voilà c'est les deux les
deux yeux luberlus voilà sinon voilà le
reste non mais c'est vrai exactement
Géraldine les deux écolos n'hésite pas à
les défis non mais moi contre écolo avec
plaisir
écolo avec plaisir mais quand tu fais
chier le monde veille de départ qui a
des mecs qui ont réservé et qui même qui
doit les vallées bosser et tout je peux
te dire là non voilà donc on va leur
parler on va faire un petit récap mais
en tout cas c'est sympa qu'il soit là
après je pense ça va être un petit peu
chaud c'est parti on y va ok
alors que les actions des écologistes se
multiplient ces derniers jours le
collectif dernière rénovation a décidé
de mener ce weekend d'une opération coup
de poing les militants écologistes qui
bloquent l'autoroute A6 en direction de
l'aéroport d'Orly pendant plus de 30
minutes ils ont donc bloqué une partie
de cette autoroute dans le Val-de-Marne
pour demander la rénovation des
passwords thermiques vraiment désolé
mais là maintenant moi j'ai pas joué je
préfère être avec ma famille mes proches
profiter et si tu viens aujourd'hui
c'est pour mon futur et pour celui de
tout le monde en fait mais très vite des
embouteillages se sont formés les
automobilistes ont commencé à
s'impatienter et la situation a dégénéré
les militants écolo bloque une autoroute
et se font attaquer par des
automobilistes alors soutenez-vous le
mouvement
[Musique]
c'est intéressant ce que vous disiez
juste avant qu'on rentre sur le plateau
sur le fait de des gens qui font chier
le monde je pense qu'il y a bien
quelqu'un qui fait chez le monde en ce
moment c'est le gouvernement qui agit
pas assez si on en trouve
pas devant les ministères pourquoi vous
allez pas devant vous allez passer
justement les gens qui vont toucher
parce qu'en fait là ce que vous faites
c'est que moi je comprends comme j'ai
dit on est colo et c'est très bien vous
devrez pour la planète et peut-être pour
le futur et peut-être pour le futur de
nos enfants nos petits-enfants de tout
ça ça je comprends tout à fait mais là
en fait ce que vous pénalisez c'est des
gars qui ont rien fait les pauvres mais
qui se retrouvent au milieu de ça et qui
disent moi je dois aller travailler moi
je dois aller chez prévu des vacances
depuis hyper longtemps j'ai mis mes
économies dans les vacances voilà et qui
se retrouve comme des cons et qui eux
n'ont rien à voir là-dedans ils peuvent
rien faire pourquoi ne pas s'attaquer
aux personnes qui sont responsables moi
je comprends les actions tout ça on l'a
dit voilà ici voilà vous faites à cause
de votre truc et votre cause elle est
bonne ça tout le monde le dit voilà
c'est vrai voilà c'est mais le problème
c'est que parfois c'est contre-productif
ça par exemple c'est contre-productif
alors Loïc
ce jour moi non mais tu vas accepter
Rachel qui était sur le compte a vu sur
le terrain et bien oui alors moi je suis
désolée en fait que ce soit tombé sur
ces gens et de les avoir bloqué c'est
pas du tout contre eux que je fais ça ça
c'est bien de le dire voilà non mais à
vendredi
elle a l'air après arrêter
seulement voilà en fait je pense que une
demi-heure de blocage sur la 6 c'est
certes très pénible et j'en ai bien
conscience mais par rapport à ce qui va
nous arriver très prochainement à toutes
et tous en fait c'est c'est rien et
c'est ça juste Rachel le vendredi soir
tu sais voilà c'était un weekend
important pour plein de gens qui étaient
économiquement je te dis à chaque fois
et le problème c'est qu'il faut essayer
d'allier économie et écologie ça c'est
vraiment le truc et c'est ce que tu
arrives à faire aucun gouvernement parce
que c'est en fait le nerf de la guerre
c'est est-ce qu'on privilégie l'économie
ou l'écologie il faut trouver le bon
équilibre entre les deux et là un
vendredi soir comme ça c'est vrai de
vacances moi je te vois Rachel je me dis
elle est sincère elle a envie de faire
avancer les choses elle pense peut-être
que à nous en fait à nous tous et les
gens ils pensent ponctuellement et moi
même pour vous là je me suis dit c'est
un mal se terminer parce que moi je veux
pas de mal j'ai pas envie en vrai voilà
quand je vous vois là les deux vous êtes
super mignon vous êtes homme et serré
vous êtes je voilà vous êtes vous avez
l'air sincère on se dit on n'a pas envie
qu'il leur arrive un truc parce que il y
a quelqu'un qui va péter un câble et qui
va dire il commence à me faire chier et
voilà donc c'est parce qu'on a envie non
plus mais c'est vrai que il faut trouver
le bon équilibre et là en fait vous
pénalisez et je comprends je comprends
votre je comprends votre cause mais vous
pénalisez des gens qui n'ont rien à voir
et qui sont déjà excédés les pauvres
vous savez les Français en ce moment il
leur arrive tous les jours des trucs
voilà ils se disent on sait même pas si
on va voir l'électricité on peut même
pas le dire le 10 du mois on peut même
plus manger on travaille comme des fous
rien l'essence c'est une tanné tout au
ils sont ils sont ils sont déjà
étranglés là ils se disent c'est notre
peut-être notre petit moment de détente
et en plus il y a ça il y a ça en plus
et c'est vrai que le timing il est il
est il est peut-être pas bon mais mais
je vous dis et puis même pour vous et
moi j'ai eu peur pour vous je vous dis
la vérité oui Kelly moi il y a un truc
que je comprends pas vous n'aimeriez pas
qu'on soit tous avec vous et qu'on vous
soyez plus excusez-moi parce que là du
coup quand vous faites un truc comme ça
moi j'ai pas envie d'être écolo parce
que quand je vous vois ça me gonfle et
ça me sort par les yeux et j'ai envie de
dire [ __ ] mais pourquoi vous cassez la
tête aux gens qui part travailler qui
partent en vacances qui économiser des
années pour pouvoir partir en vacances
qui vont peut-être les raté à cause de
vous et moi je me dis pourquoi ne pas
aller voir directement le gouvernement
ceux qui vont vraiment chier au lieu
d'aller voir les gens qui sont tous être
avec vous ça que j'ai envie d'être avec
vous mais en voyant ça j'ai pas envie
Loïc et Rachel est-ce que c'est la bonne
technique qui vous voulez
on est entièrement d'accord je pense que
nous on est on est aussi attristé avec
ça que vous en arrivez là c'était pas le
but et d'ailleurs vous nous avez pas
invité sur le plateau quand on était
devant l'Élysée à essayer d'interpeller
le gouvernement
et en fait c'est ça le problème c'est
que les médias nous invitent que quand
on fait des choses comme ça regardez
aujourd'hui
et en début d'année en fait toutes ces
autres choses on s'est adressé au
Gouvernement et encore on parle que de
du mouvement au dernier rénovation ce
collectif qui est tout jeune mais ça
fait 50 ans qu'il y a des scientifiques
qui s'adressent au gouvernement qui
essayent d'avoir des méthodes plus
douces plus légales et ça ne marche pas
on demande on veut défendre une cause
mais non on défend pas une cause moi
désolé je vais être égoïste en disant ça
mais moi j'ai peur pour mes proches pour
ma famille on est tous sur ce plateau
concerné c'est à dire d'ici à peine 10
ans c'est effrayant vraiment le GIEC
nous explique ça on va commencer à
manquer de nourriture d'eau même en
France donc moi ça veut dire que ma
petite sœur ma mère elles vont être en
danger ça ou pour une cause de flou
écologiste
ça tout le monde l'entend et bien sûr on
voit on voit bien que je vais te dire
même le temps actuellement je vais te
dire on est on est le premier novembre
il fait 25 degrés dehors
voilà et tout le monde me dit c'est
n'importe quoi en fait même on sent bien
qu'il y a un truc qui qui qui part en
cacahuète ça je te le dis on le sent on
le voit bien et c'est vrai que voilà
quand moi je vous jure en ce moment
quand je bois une
20 minutes une autoroute comme ça 2000
personnes d'abord vous polluez est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est cette solution
là est-ce que vous est-ce que vous savez
quel moyen de transport polluent le plus
par exemple quel moyen à un moteur pollu
le plus pourquoi pas attaqué
ça soit sur l'autoroute on va défendre
la cause et qu'est-ce qui pollue le plus
c'est écolo un champignon c'est un
paquebot à Ken c'est un million de
voitures vous répondez pas
un million de voitures allez emmerder
les avions allez emmerder les paquebots
allez emmerder des trucs comme ça ça ne
veut rien dire ce que vous faites et je
rejoins Cyril vous mettez votre votre
sécurité en danger c'est super dangereux
vous rendez pas compte que vous avez pu
tomber sur un fou avec un casque de
scooter qui va vous dérouiller vous
allez prendre une c'est super dangereux
et je suis pas pour à là-bas je suis
pour l'écologie mais quand je vois ça je
suis pas pour alors on va voir justement
avant que Rachel et Loïc répondent à
Raymond parce que j'aimerais bien qu'il
réponde regardez tous les moments de
tension qui a eu regardé
[Musique]
alors
oui j'entends ce que vous dites et en
fait il y a plein d'autres moyens qui
ont déjà été faits pour lutter des
marches pour le climat s'engager en
politique signer des pétitions sauf
qu'en fait ça n'a pas fonctionné et
c'est pour ça que en fait on fait ce
genre de choses c'est parce que on a
déjà essayé d'autres moyens qui voilà
qui n'ont pas fonctionné depuis 50 ans
tout un tas de personnes
alerte sur la situation climatique et en
fait ça n'a toujours pas bougé et vous
pensez que ça ça va faire bouger les
choses individuels c'est un sujet super
important on a tous commencé à faire des
gestes à la maison et déjà c'est
compliqué surtout pour des gens ou en
demande de baisser le chauffage etc
c'est des gens n'ont pas les moyens de
faire ses efforts mais le problème c'est
que même en allant jusqu'au bout de ces
efforts individuels ça ne suffit pas
aujourd'hui l'effort conséquent à faire
il est collectif il est au niveau de
l'État donc ça veut dire que même si
nous on fait ces modes d'action et que
vous proposiez ça ne suffira pas donc en
fait si on veut attendre que la
catastrophe qu'on a annoncé arrive
la semaine dernière l'ONU c'est plus un
scénario plus 3 degrés donc ça ça parle
pas beaucoup maintenant mais ça veut
dire très concrètement ça veut dire 3,5
milliards de personnes d'ici 2050 qui
devronter leur zone d'habitation 3,5
milliards de personnes c'est colossal la
vague de migration en Méditerranée
c'était 200000 personnes on en a parlé
partout c'était un cataclysme à gérer
imaginez ce que ça va être des centaines
de millions de personnes et je finis
juste sur un chiffre là-dessus il y a
une personne sur 10 qui mourait pendant
ses déplacements donc si on prend siffle
de 10% et qu'on l'applique à ces
chiffres complètement démentiels ils
sont de 3 milliards et demi d'ici à
20,30 ans mais d'ici à 10 ans on va déjà
va voir potentiellement un milliard de
personnes sur les routes ça fait plus de
100 millions de morts c'est deux guerres
mondiales d'ici la prochaine décennie et
à nouveau on va être impacté c'est un
domino tout ça nous Français ça c'est
rien par rapport à ce qu'on alors vous
faites quoi s'il vous plait s'il vous
plaît non mais s'il vous plaît vous
faites quoi dans la vie Loïc et Raphaël
faites quoi dans la vie
civique d'accord vous travaillez je
travaille en plus et en plus vous faites
des actions ça vous prend beaucoup
mon avenir celui de tout le monde en
fait que je
suis chef d'entreprise j'ai trois
salariés d'accord
parce que au-delà de ça c'est vrai qu'il
y a beaucoup de gens aussi qui me disent
voilà on s'en fout des voitures trucs
aujourd'hui
mais là on parle pas que des voitures je
vous le dis aujourd'hui ce qu'on parle
on parle de deux gens qui sont au bout
de leur vie qui doivent aller bosser qui
doivent faire des trucs il y en a qui
bossaient vendredi soir je vous dis qui
était bloqué et qui sont dit ben voilà
c'est pas possible vous vouliez bloquez
combien de temps c'était quoi le truc en
fait combien de temps
jusqu'à ce que les forces de l'ordre
interviennent l'idée c'est très simple
en fait derrière innovation qu'est-ce
que c'est c'est exiger du gouvernement
qu'ils établissent un plan de rénovation
thermique des bâtiments d'ici à 2040
pourquoi la rénovation thermique déjà
c'est un Français sur 5 c'est 12
millions de personnes qui sont
concernées donc il y en a sur plateau il
y en ailleurs on en connaît tous c'est
12 millions de personnes qui vont passer
un hiver qui va être un des plus froids
des 10 dernières années dans des
conditions déplorables avec un pouvoir
d'achat complètement dégradé si on avait
si on était froid on savait que ça va
être le plus froid des dix dernières
années c'est ce qui est annoncé dans les
traduction n'importe quoi pour l'instant
on n'est pas encore quoi c'est n'importe
quoi comment on peut savoir comment il
va faire froid au mois de février au
mois de janvier arrêtez 2 minutes
il y a des petites prévisions quand même
il va faire -8 voilà à Strasbourg il
fera moins 12 à Marseille il fera 6
excuse-moi tu es Évelyne délire toi
arrêtez de tomber dans de la famille
moi j'ai juste un truc
c'est hyper bien vos actions
des tableaux qui ont été dégradés
grand pollueur je vous dis comme la
Chine les États-Unis l'Inde la Russie
nous on est une cacahuète en fait
vous pouvez faire tout ce que vous
voulez pas la France qui va sauver la
planète ça c'est sûr et certain donc je
vous le dis la France nous on est un un
P sur une toile cirée c'est la vérité ce
que je peux poser une question non
c'est la vérité
on est tellement minime nous ça sert à
rien en fait on se dit
moi je m'engage la France peut être le
plus gros pollueur du monde on polluera
beaucoup moins que tout le monde ça veut
dire il y en a que que que les grands
pays voilà c'est pas nous qui allons
envoyer la planète dans le mur alors
moi je m'engage voilà comme je le disais
pour pour mes proches mon avenir parce
que je m'inquiète pour tout ça et je
fais totalement confiance
aux personnes vivant dans d'autres pays
pour elle aussi voilà prendre dans les
autres pays ça avance pas trop elle est
devant les ambassades
aujourd'hui
qui sont engagés sur les mêmes campagnes
actuellement il y a 11 pays dans le
monde qui font la même chose et citoyens
se mettent en Chine
est-ce qu'on est des Chinois ici est-ce
qu'on est des citoyens chinois on est
des citoyens français
ils nous expliquera aussi pourquoi c'est
vrai qu'il veut encore communiquer
Christian qui est salam et c'est
incroyable ce sera dans un instant en
direct sur TPMP pour le moment nous
sommes avec Loïc et Rachel qui ont
participé à l'action ils ont bloqué une
autoroute c'était vendredi soir et c'est
vrai que ils nous ont dit un truc
c'est eux c'est pour alerter le
gouvernement c'est ça histoire
c'est pour interpeller le public les
invités à s'engager dans les résistances
civiles pour augmenter la pression sur
le gouvernement mais qu'est-ce que le
gouvernement va céder si la perturbe
face au gouvernement et bien qui établit
une feuille de route pour la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments d'ici à 2040 qui
s'occupe des 12 millions de personnes
qui vivent dans des passoires thermiques
on a 2200 morts par an qui vit dans des
passements thermiques et qui meurt à
cause des conditions de vie dans ses
logements moi comme je voulais comme je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure moi les
deux très mignons ce que je vous ai dit
la pub c'est vrai vous faites des trucs
c'est c'est bien d'avoir une cause
d'essayer de la défendre etc et c'est
une belle cause on va pas se raconter
l'histoire c'est quoi qui en quoi qu'on
en dise une cause incroyable après c'est
vrai que vous attaquez aux
automobilistes vous attaquez à la
population ça pour moi vous attaquez aux
institutions je peux comprendre ce que
ce sont eux les responsables mais là
vous attaquez à des gens qui n'ont rien
à voir là-dedans Gilles tu défends leur
action vous êtes mes héros
parce que vous allez sauver la planète
contre tous ceux qui disent non là et
vous vous AG alors oui on est bloqué une
demi-heure mais c'est quoi de rater un
avion alors qu'on veut sauver la planète
tu rates ton avion tu fais quoi j'aurais
été fier
là tu peux leur dire tu peux leur dire
ils peuvent attendre une semaine ou pas
de malade dans les bouchons l'ambulance
exactement
on a laissé une ambulance bloquée non
merci au revoir comment tu peux savoir
quand tu es assise là le bouchon que tu
as fait jusqu'à la Porte d'Italie il y a
un hôpital Gustave Roussy spécialisé
pour le cancer comment tu peux savoir
que l'hôpital est passe tu es assise là
comment tu peux savoir ton hôpital tu
l'as ton ambulance tu l'as débloqué 10
km plus loin comment tu débloques une
ambulance 10 km plus longtemps
explique-moi tu préviens qui m'a dit non
s'il vous plaît Daniel perles les eaux
elle est enceinte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai été bloqué et en fait je regardais
l'heure parce que ma maman son aide à
domicile devait partir
mais oui j'étais parce que moi je dois
traverser l'autoroute pour rentrer chez
moi donc vendredi soir mais non non en
taxi
alors je vous aimez bien je peux plus
vous dire
mon exemple il est tout bête en fait moi
je n'ai jamais pris l'âme de viande de
ma vie j'arrête pas de le dire je n'ai
pas de voiture je prends de temps en
temps les taxis je fais tout bien et là
je me retrouve bloqué avec un cas quand
même embêtant parce que s'il aide à
domicile doit partir parce que elle elle
s'occupe après d'une autre personne âgée
donc elle ne peut pas m'attendre donc
voilà essayez de penser à des gens comme
moi quand vous ferez une autre action
parce qu'en plus vous avez besoin qu'on
soit vous avez non mais vous voyez ce
que je veux dire vous avez besoin qu'on
soit avec vous dans cette action là vous
le dites vous-même donc vous pouvez pas
vous rendre un populaire auprès de gens
comme moi qui font qui essayent de faire
tout bien donc penser voilà juste penser
un petit peu à ça pour vous faire une
autre action
qu'on se met tout le monde ado juste je
voulais vous dire que il y avait des
gens bloqués qui nous ont soutenus
c'est votre maman c'est ça qui avait
besoin d'une aide ou je sais pas
imaginez dans quelques années ce qu'on
évoquait votre maman est un risque de
perdre la vie moi je m'amère vis dans le
sud elle a 68 ans là elle a passé l'été
mais difficilement moi j'ai hyper long
dans les 2050
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je l'adore en plus mais là 2050
sur les routes dans 10 ans où est-ce
qu'elles vont aller chercher leur eau et
leur nourriture elles vont venir ici et
c'est normal on ferait la même chose
alors place mais ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir partager ça veut dire que votre
maman l'électricité tout ce dont on a
déjà des difficultés à gérer aujourd'hui
on va avoir beaucoup de mal dans à peine
10 ans mais vous réalisez on va tous le
vivre
on est déjà passé par tous les recours
légaux ça ne marche pas et d'ailleurs
vous en êtes là alors
il dit un truc
qui est vrai Loïc il dit la vérité
là-dessus et là autant j'étais pas
d'accord autant Loïc tu as raison sur un
truc voilà regardez ce soir on en parle
l'action
ils sont là si on pouvait faire ça si on
pouvait arriver sur votre plateau en
faisant une simple pétition tu fais une
chenille dans une impasse personne
minimiser le respect perturbation
comprend toutes les précautions
possibles on n'est pas là vraiment pour
s'en prendre physiquement aujourd'hui et
malheureusement c'est rien par rapport à
ce qui arrive des rangement dans sa
journée j'aime bien échanger vous voulez
que je vous dise avant que vous arriviez
absolument franchement j'étais
hypervéler je le dis je pense que
j'étais tout comme tous les
automobilistes et tous les gens qui
n'ont rien et je vous ai écouté et ben
tu vois je vous aime bien quand même
et ben c'est vrai tu veux pas nous c'est
vrai et tous on est on est tous les
mêmes réactions
on leur tombe dessus on leur dit oui ce
que vous faites ça sert à rien en
attendant à chaque fois qu'il y a une
action comme ça que celle-ci qui est
menée qui est quand même non violente et
Pacifique il faut le rappeler même quand
il y avait des tableaux etc on en parle
et on en parle du fond leur but c'est
d'interpeller les gouvernements si on
vient de parler du fond dans cette
émission
que ça sensibilise non seulement les
gens qui nous regardent il y a beaucoup
de gens qui nous regardent et ça
sensibilise aussi le gouvernement et
c'est pas en faisant un statut facebook
et en postant de tweets qui vont sur
invité sur les plateaux c'est une
réalité pantoufle qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire ah c'est moi
vous vous rendez compte un peu du
discours c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
quelqu'un d'autre va avoir une autre
cause quelqu'un on est que dans la
violence regardez la raquette
radicalisation ce weekend pour les
bassines et tout ça moi ça me mais si ça
me désole si vous avez vu ça donne une
mauvaise image pour moi
la cause de départ est hyper bonne et il
y a trop de radicalisations
dans la tête des gens vous êtes des
emmerdeurs et ça c'est grave
je suis désolé je trouve bien plus utile
sur ce plateau effectivement que sur
l'autoroute évidemment qu'on a tous
conscience de l'épuisement des
ressources des problèmes par exemple la
surconsommation au réchauffement
climatique mais moi je crois pas je
crois pas malgré tout à l'écologie
punitive à l'écologie brutale parce
qu'en fait le ensuite en fait c'est
qu'on soit tous derrière vous c'est
qu'on embrasse tous votre cause qui est
la nôtre qui devrait être la nôtre qui
devrait être la même on devrait avoir
tous la même cause mais moi j'arrive pas
à comprendre pourquoi on ne fait rien si
c'est si grave quel est l'intérêt par
exemple du gouvernement de dire mais
rien à [ __ ] du réchauffement
climatique de climatique on va tous
crever quel est le problème en fait
pourquoi ils font ça c'est du cynisme
c'est une excellente question non mais
en toute la pose aussi moi je trouve que
ce serait intéressant de peut-être
poser leur question moi vraiment on se
pose la question tous mais faites-les
venir sur un plateau on n'a pas besoin
d'être là faites ça entre vous mais
interrogez-les sur ça aujourd'hui la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments qui a
une première étape pour aller nous
sauver tous sur ce sujet ils le font pas
alors que ça permet aux Français de
vivre dans de meilleures conditions
c'est plus 1000 euros par an de savoir
d'achat c'est une autonomie c'est 45% de
toutes l'énergie qui ont lancé ça à
l'échelle nationale dans le pays donc ça
augmente notre indépendance
l'année dernière un chiffre pour vous
montrer à quel point ils sont à côté de
la plaque l'année dernière 60000
logements qui ont été rénovés en termes
de rénovation globale ça veut dire qu'on
va dans bon sens sur un objectif de 800
000 logements ça fait moins de 1 sur 10
si on retourne sur les bandes de l'école
et qu'on note le gouvernement ça fait
une note de 2 sur 20 donc aujourd'hui le
gouvernement cet objectif de 800.000
c'est pareil c'est pour tenir les
accords de Paris c'est pour éviter
toutes ces tous cette catastrophe dont
on a parlé aujourd'hui par rapport à cet
objectif ils sont à deux sur 20 vous
vous rendez compte vous rentrez à
l'heure vous rentrez avec deux sur
un fond
si on change tout
blanc on peut parler technique à un
autre moment mais c'est globalité
pour les foyers les plus modestes c'est
ce qu'on demande oui voilà soutenez vos
moments oui à 13 % de non à 86%
des gens qui ne soutiennent pas le
mouvement voilà après voilà je vous dis
c'est vrai qu'on voit bien qu'il y a
quand même un truc qui va pas quand on
voit qu'il fait 35 degrés le 1er
novembre et qu'ils annoncent un Noël à
mon avis tu veux mettre les boules elles
vont fondre 2 secondes
[Rires]
mettre du polystyrène là je pense que la
neige je sais pas si elle est marié bon
voilà et c'est vrai que voilà donc je
vous le dis mais bon faites attention
quand même et puis c'est vrai que je
vous dis voilà vous êtes vous êtes
considéré comme des comme des emmerdeurs
et ça me fait aussi de la peine ce que
vous essayez de faire le le max pour
votre cause voilà en tout cas
bien sûr allez vas-y Rachel moi je
voulais dire que en fait je suis séparée
de devoir en arriver un stade où je
m'assois sur la route pour demander euh
une mesure qui fait consensus parce que
la rénovation thermique des bâtiments ça
va augmenter la qualité de vie de tout
le monde c'est pour tout le monde qu'on
fait ça
ils crèvent de faim déjà tu crois que je
crois que les enfants et là l'argent
pour soigner les gens qui vivent dans
des passoires céramiques la convention
citoyenne pour le climat qui a été
initié par le président qu'il a ensuite
rejeté du revers de la main il
recommandait d'investir 13 millions de
dollars de d'euros par an vous rendez
compte 10 milliards de dépenses tous les
et si tu si tu avais du mal à finir les
dix derniers jours du mois les 15 jours
tu t'occuperas pas des fenêtres tu
t'occuperas de savoir ce qu'il y a dans
ton assiette et là tu veux c'est pour ça
que c'est au gouvernement
parce qu'ils ont raison
parce qu'ils ont raison dans leur combat
écolo ils ont raison
mais ce qui demande
oui qu'est-ce que tu veux mais non j'ai
dit que ça coûte sur le fait qu'ils vont
le faire ils vont le faire ils vont
changer les fenêtres des appartements
moins énergivores ils vont le faire mais
balancer des millions tout de suite
comme ça pour des fenêtres et bloquer
l'autoroute pour demain on veut que tous
les appartements ils soient en PVC en
double vitrage c'est peut-être pas comme
ça que ça va se passer du jour au
lendemain fausses faites en sorte qu'on
soit avec vous en fait on sort le
sondage faites en sorte qu'on soit avec
vous et emmerdez pas les gens
pourquoi
on serait pas sur le plateau si on avait
pas été sur la route on trouve pas pas
non plus on est d'accord on est tous
d'accord en fait on trouve pas ça normal
c'est le gouvernement qui doit agir
c'est le gouvernement neuf ce plan de
rénovation on disparaît mais je
comprenais ça on disparaît du jour au
lendemain non mais nous on arrête en
tout cas ce chantier de la rénovation on
arrête la perturbation sur les routes
il y a plus de réchauffement climatique
bah non on va lutter sur d'autres
plantes mais en tout cas ça sera une
brique en avant justement ce sera une
brique en avance ce sera conséquent 12
millions de Français qui sont concernés
2200 morts par an combien de fois il
faut le rappeler c'est faux c'est une
priorité le gouvernement doit agir merci
en tout cas tu termines la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments c'est un pas
important à faire c'est pas le seul mais
justement si le gouvernement est pas
capable de faire ça qu'est-ce qui va se
passer pour toutes les autres choses
qu'il y a à faire un dernier truc à dire
sur les fenêtres toi
allez nouveau logement ils le font il y
a des aides pour ceux qui prennent un
pavillon pas
des aides pour pour avoir des des
maisons mieux isolées les nouveaux
bâtiments sont super bien isolés on le
fait il y a des anciens battants 2 sur
20 on en a parlé les chiffres sont là
deux sur 20 écoute merci beaucoup
rappelez-vous bien parlez-vous par la
fenêtre
mais c'est vrai merci merci
Loïc et merci Rachel de Dieu merci à
vous deux merci vraiment vraiment
[Applaudissements]